This [inaudible]
fellow snatched
the credit you justly deserved.
He's a rat, like the Jews.
And rats must be eradicated.
It's only the
very first Nobel.
You will win the next one.
In this class we will deal
only with what has been proven.
The existence of
molecules has not.
You brought up Mr. Besso.
Such a charming
dinner companion.
I do hope you return sooner
rather than later Mr. Besso.
[non-english speech] You
won't even know I'm gone.
What a lovely thought.
Dear Frau Wintere, I write
and ask you to share my feelings
with your dearest Marie.
She deserves more attention
than I have to give.
Mother, you know very well
that I have someone else now.
Mileva, you're
the love of my life.
That creature, she's
just a nasty little witch.
She's no witch.
She's my wife.
He's very busy, Papa.
He can't even get a job.
There is a position I
know at the patent office.
I'm a scientist, Marcel.
I'm better than a clerkship.
Welcome to the patent
office, Herr Einstein.